الانفجار يسبب هذا الانفجار الضخم في تلك
المنطقه الانفجار كان بالتزامن مع التحليق
طائره مسيره عند ضفاف الفرات الانفجار
وقعه في مستودع للايرانيين تحديدا
المستودع للصواريخ قصيره المدى وكان هناك
انفجار وتهدم مباني اي نغم يتسبب بتهدم
مباني وتدمير بشكل تلك بشكل كبير في تلك
المنطقه حتى اللحظه هناك اربعه قتلى
مؤكدين واكثر ونحو ثمانيه جرحى في هذا
الانفجار او التفجير من طائره مسيره
استهدفت هذه المنطقه بالتزامن مع وصول
شاحنه كبيره محمله
بانابيب تستخدم باجل تصنيع صواريخ قصيره
المدى في تلك البقعه من التراب السوري
المسيطر عليها من قبل الايرانيين ويوجد
فيها مشفى ايراني
في تلك المنطقه ايضا يوجد مصنع لتصنيع بين
المناطق المدنيه حقيقه الامر لتصنيع او
تجهيز او تجميع الصواريخ صواريخ قصيره
المدى الايرانيه التابعه للميليشيات في
هذه البقعه من الجغرافيا السوريه ويوجد في
تلك المنطقه مساكن لحجاج او ما يعرف بقاده
من حزب الله والحرس الثوري الايراني
يقتلون في تلك المنطقه لا لهم ولا غير لغه
يتسبب بهذا الانفجار الهائل ويتسبب بتساقط
اجزاء من مباني وتدبير التي شاهدناه
بالصوت والصوره وارسلنا شريط مصور وصور
حجم هذا الانفجار الضخم في اتجاه البقعه
هذه الصور ان نتابعها ايضا معك على شاشه
قناه العربيه سيد رامي لكن هذه المنطقه
كما تفضلت هي تابع النظام السوري وايضا
بها ميليشيات متحالفه معها ما طبيعه هذه
نعم تفضل
تتواجد فيها ميليشيات حزب الله وميليشيات
ايرانيه ويوجد فيها المشفى الايراني او ما
يعرف بمشفى البوليرا في تلك المنطقه
ومصطفات ايرانيه